(upbeat groovy music)
- Hi again, I'm Linda, and today we're gonna work
on a pasta installation that has tons
of different interesting shapes of pasta.
And we're gonna have so much fun with the pastabilities.
We are going to build out an art piece
that will have a core, a heart,
and that core in the middle will be made of a raviolone,
raviolone just means big raviolo.
So that's our center, that is the center
of our universe right there.
^Number two is going to be a bunch of square ravioli.
^With all of this pasta, when we're done today
we are going to boil it all, we're gonna eat
all of these different colors, but sometimes
there are just pasta scraps that have become too dry.
A couple of uses for them, you can actually bake them,
turn them into crackers, use them to scoop up
a cheese or a dip that you've made.
I feel like pasta and pasta making for me is just
this zen art that's very meditative.
We will have triangle ravioli around the squares.
Those will be orange, they're really funky and pretty.
^You can't forget the farfalle, farfalle is like
the classic shape, the little butterflies.
When I was making pasta and I was a little kid
I could barely hold a knife and we didn't have
any fancy tools for pasta making so farfalle
I would say was a really approachable easy one
to start just because that one is such a classic.
And once you learn to really make it,
you can make a thousand of them.
^This is my friend the pasta bike, nice to meet you.
Next up is a shape called paccheri.
Paccheri are rolled on a dowel.
It's a good thing that we're all adults here
because it's gonna remind you of something else
but get your mind out of the gutter
and truly just enjoy the artistry of the process.
But I think you can really appreciate and enjoy it
on many levels.
^Next up we have culurgiones.
Culurgiones are from Sardinia, a little island off of Italy.
It's these little squashy chubby little dumplings
that are rolled and shaped in a very interesting
and unique way.
So right now I'm actually really into pasta origami.
I'm getting a lot of inspiration from other
sort of art forms and how I can bring that to my pasta.
So for me these shapes are so cool
and I love being able to show people some of the classics
that we've made today.
^We have ingannapreti.
Ingannapreti means trick the priest!
What's the story behind that?
And the trick is that they look
like they're little tortellini
but there's nothing inside, surprise!
We have these really cool just wispy strands of fettuccine.
Our strands are, again, all of the colors represented.
It actually looks really pretty already,
imagine what it's gonna look like with all the colors!
I always thought my entire life
that I was an artist and everybody always told me
that I wasn't and that I was terrible.
Well it turns out that I just hadn't found my medium.
I get really inspired by the entire world around me
when I'm making pasta.
I feel like when you sort of have found your medium
you're just always looking for ways to express it
and I do think to me, brings a little bit
of a deeper sense of soul to my work.
^Pasta la vista, baby.
- [Man] Oh yes!
(upbeat groovy music)